You're doing this beautiful movie
and I was watching the trailer
and all I wanted to do was pull up a blanket and get
in my cozies and just nuzzle into this movie.
And you're playing Jackie
in "Merry Liddle Christmas Wedding,"
dealing with the challenges of a step family.
And this movie also deals with blended family issues.
And so I'm and I was in a movie called "Blended"
and years later, I have found myself now in one as well.
And we really are a close family
and spend a lot of time together.
But you know, things are changing.
Years go on, dynamics change.
I could use a little of your film's advice.
What, tell me.
(laughs) No, you know what's funny
is I remember reading the script and saying,
I think that this is gonna be like really on time
when it comes to, like you said,
blended families and how that first process
of even just going through with the wedding
and reading through that in the script, I was like,
oh my gosh, like Jackie has a real battle here.
You know what I mean
with making sure that she's not doing too much,
but she's doing just enough to make sure that, you know,
the fiance is like, you know, comfortable,
the kids are comfortable,
but she has to be comfortable in and find her space
in their life and where she fits as well.
And so doing that,
I just remember thinking to myself, like,
what is that feeling like?
Which to me is always, probably walking on eggshells,
because you want to say the right thing.
You're hoping that like,
the things that you're suggesting are the right suggestions
and it's tricky because they're also younger kids.
So because they're younger kids, this is a like a new,
a new transition for them.
And you want it to be as seamless as possible.
(audience applauds)
Everything you just said is so on point
and incredibly respectful and true
to like how humans think and feel.
I was literally, like,
I was worried the camera was gonna go to me,
'cause I was like, everything you said.
(laughs)
And even if you have kids or not,
I think it's just sort of,
a thing where we're all trying to figure out, as you said,
the right thing to do or say,
or insert yourself or step back.
And it's the dance,
it's the dance of life.
(audience applauds)
For sure, I mean I'm sure this holiday season,
I should actually put like tissue boxes all over the house,
because everything makes me cry right now.
I'm so hormonal and emotional.
Like I was, me and Titan had the best conversation yesterday
and in between our conversation,
like I just burst out crying because I was just like,
I just, how can I love somebody so much?
And then one thought goes to another thought,
then the holiday, like I got the, hold on,
I got the tree up over here (laughs).
Oh, it's beautiful.
(audience applauds)
I'm just like, I'm in the spirit already.
I'm so excited.
Well, Kelly, I think this movie is gonna be so great.
"Merry Liddle Christmas Wedding" airs Saturday,
November 28th at eight, seven central on Lifetime.
I think this movie is gonna be so great
for so many people and I'm gonna be cuddled up watching it.
Absolutely learning lots of things and just enjoying it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Kelly.
Muah.
(upbeat music)